as we've talked about in other videos by
the time we get into the 15th century
timur's persia and central asia has been
fragmented you have many of timur's
descendants with their own kingdoms
especially in central asia in 1483
in the central asian city of andijan now
part of eastern uzbekistan
you have one of timur's grandson's great
grandsons born
bobber and at the age of 12 bobber takes
the throne of fergana after the death of
his father
now over the next few decades he tries
to consolidate control he tries to take
control of samarkand loses control and
then a fergata and keeps repeatedly
losing control early in the 16th century
he is able to take kabul and then
decides to focus on india instead of
central asia
in 1526 famously with the use of canons
which had not been used in a significant
way in the indian subcontinent until
that time babur was able to defeat
ibrahim lodhi of the delhi sultanate and
come to power in northern india and you
can see in this blue grey color this is
the territory that babur was able to
rule over until his death in 1530. mogul
is just the persian word for mongol
remember babur is a descendant of timor
who is a turco mongolian conqueror on
his mother's side he claims descendancy
from genghis khan
but persian is the language of his court
and so it significantly increases the
persian influence in north indian
culture after his death his son humayun
comes to power
humayun has difficulty retaining power
he has various family rivalries to
contend with and eventually he is
dethroned by the pashtun suri dynasty he
goes to the safavids and with their help
is able to retake control but then trips
on stairs and dies and then his son
akbar comes to power
now akbar is perhaps most famous of all
of the mogul rulers as you can see he is
able to rule over india for some time as
just mentioned humayun essentially had
to re-conquer retake the throne and his
hold on power was relatively weak but
now akbar is able to expand the
territory that you see in this light
purple move color he's able to increase
the central authority and perhaps most
importantly he tries to unify india
culturally
the moguls are muslim and are relatively
tolerant up through akbar and to some
degree jahangir of other religions but
akbar takes a very pluralistic approach
he's famous for holding court with
religious scholars throughout the empire
and even trying to merge the religions
creating what some would consider a
religion of his own that would later be
called deen illahi the religion of god
many jain and hindu principles appeal to
him he becomes a vegetarian he bans the
slaughtering of cows
at his death in 1605 his son jahangir
comes to power
historians consider jahangir to be
relatively tolerant like akbar and to
continue the interest in the sciences
and the arts that you saw in the mughal
court under akbar but he's a little bit
more controversial as we talked about in
the sikhism video he famously tortures
and executes guru arjun some would say
it would be it was because guru arjun
was siding with jahangir's son who was
trying to rebel others would say that it
was because guru arjun was getting a
following in punjab and that jahangir
was insecure of his own hold-on power
and decided to execute gurajin
but he is succeeded by his son shah
jahan
who becomes decisively less tolerant
his reign however is known as the golden
age of mogul architecture with the
crowning achievement arguably the taj
mahal which is a mausoleum that he
commissions in the 1630s to house the
body of his dead wife
as you can see here it's housed in agra
and agra and delhi at various points
during the mughal empire are the capital
there's a few moments when it is at
lahore
he is eventually imprisoned by his son
aurangzeb
aurangzeb is considered a very strong
and authoritarian ruler you can see here
that he is able to expand the territory
of the mughal empire well into south
india
at its maximum extent the mogul empire
is now rivaling the amount of territory
that was controlled by the morya empire
roughly 2 000 years before this time
despite being the last truly strong
mogul emperor he's also known as the
least tolerant of the emperors
after the death of aurangzeb in 1707 he
succeeded by weaker and weaker mogul
rulers the 18th century you see a
significant decline in the power of the
moguls the territory they have delhi is
famously sacked by nader shah the
persian conqueror as we get into the
second half of the 18th century the
british are able to chip away more and
more and more territory not just from
the moguls but from other indian rulers
as well which we will see in future
videos